les changements climatiques gagnent du
terrain et le Québec n'est pas épargné
au cours des derniers mois la tempête
Fiona s'écoule les Îles de la Madeleine
un déluge s'est abattu sur Montréal et
un des ritcho a déferlé sur le Québec
causant de nombreux dégâts ce dernier
événement à lui seul a coûté plus de 70
millions de dollars à Hydro-Québec mais
surtout laisser plus de 550 million du
réseau sans électricité et certains
pendant plusieurs jours
hydro-Québec a donc dévoilé un plan
d'action qui va de la gestion des pannes
aux conditions de travail des
techniciens sur le terrain on a toujours
dû jongler avec les aléas les caprices
de Dame Nature lorsqu'on constate quand
on regarde la science du climat c'est
que c'est risque là change s'accroître
son plus variables la société d'État
veut notamment remplacer des poteaux
électriques en bois fragilisés en cas de
chaleur extrême par d'autres composés de
plus résistants
coûteuse que l'installation de poteaux
ici Daniel Piaggio Radio-Canada Montréal